so often in maths the bridge the path to
know something learn something that you
don't understand yet is to compare it to
something that you do know that you do
understand so that's why I be getting
here because this is something that we
could all do 5 times 12 what's 5 times
12 equal to 1660 yes 6 0 okay perfect
that's exactly right
okay and there's a few different ways
that you can see that for example you
can say are 12 is 3 times 4 right
so if five times 12 is a bit too big for
you you can do 5 times 3 and then that's
15 and then you block like that by 4 you
get 60 Santiam yep you could say 5 is
actually 10 divided by 2 so you could do
2 times sorry you could do 12 times 10
120 and then do the division which would
give you know we'll say P in that you'll
get the same result okay or you could
have your times now I want to show you
one other way of doing it which because
we have all these other strategies to
doing which works just fine you probably
don't think about but will be very
instructive for this ok 5 times 12 I'm
going to rewrite it in a little
different way okay this is 5 times now
I'm gonna choose to break up a 12 rather
than say 3 times 4 I'm gonna break it up
into 10 plus 2 this is still the same
thing right 10 plus 2 is still 12
and I'll put the brackets around to
indicate that whole thing is maybe
elsewhere by 5 all of it that's why it's
12 okay now if you remember back to last
year we learnt you know we talked about
a little wasn't stuff like that right
shortcuts laws shortcuts we learn
particular
for this called the distributive law and
this big important man the distributive
law in case you and what it means is
when you say five times these things the
ten of the two that five times it
distributes across all the numbers
inside the brackets right that's why
it's the distributive law so there'll be
five times the ten right everyone inside
the brackets get to five times it gets
handed out to everyone how would that
look all up the next line
well five times ten of course is fifteen
and five times two is 10 which is as you
expected it's still 60 it's still the
same thing it's just another way of
looking at it
but we're going to use this idea that
whatever is at the foot will get
distributed to everything inside the
brackets when we look at algebraic
expressions because even though we're
doing the same thing here it looks
rather different so sometimes you bring
you kind of weird out and don't know
what to do let's have a go excuse me I'm
going to use this same principle of
distribution okay again I've got a five
bucket right I'm going to distribute the
five to everything that's inside the
brackets first there's an N then there
will be a three okay so five times M
with my algebraic you know abbreviations
I would just write 5 m so there's the
first distribution with the second 105
by three which gives me 15 perfect and
that's it I've expanded it can you see I
don't have any brackets anymore they've
left behind I've got the whole
expression has been evaluated okay so
it's fine this is not complicated it's
exactly the same thing
doing here but with algebra in the mix
let's give this one again right there's
something on it yeah
take out the front and again it's
distributed but you just have to be a
little cautious because for starters is
it in there
no big deal 8 times air will give me but
this 8 doesn't just distribute to a 2 it
distributes to power minus 2 right so
the the sign comes along for the ride
just like this plus becomes a plus here
this bonus will also become those over
here so this should be minus a by 2 16
okay so I have taken this which has
brackets I've gotten rid of the brackets
and I have expanded that's what this
process is called this is called X okay
so this is support let's just do two
final examples and then election have a
bit of practice right here what I've got
out the front
this guy's got a minus sign right
remember how we said the minus sign
comes along for the ride right well this
time the minus side comes along for the
ride twice do you see why it happens
twice the minus three gets distributed
once and then it gets distributed twice
so they're both got to get the minus
three apply to them minus 3 times n
should give us minus 3 n well done
but then minus 3 again times 4 will give
me minus 12 right that's three times
four can you see what's happened now
I've got my decides twice because I've
distributed twice okay I suppose if I
put another term in there like three
terms I get three minus signs I would've
eaten last one now I could do this first
term fairly easily I'm gonna stop
drawing the arrows because I can I think
you can see what's going on right
I'll go go - fourth time today - four V
but what happens to the second term this
is it's the isn't it
Rachel yeah fantastic I've got minus 4
times minus 5 where you got to buy the
signs they cancel each other out you
just end up with a positive and of
course the sizes is 20 okay so that
makes sense so can you see here what by
this sign at the front and it's become 2
here because it gets distributed twice
this guy got distributed twice - it's
just that he collided with this guy and
they cancel each other out
makes sense